[Music]
all right tonight it appears that other
so-called Russian bombshell has fallen
completely flat
The Guardian Today reported without any
evidence vague sourcing that former
Trump campaign manager Paul Manafort and
WikiLeaks founder Julian Assange met
multiple times between 2013 and 2016 at
the Ecuadorian Embassy in London well
tonight Paul Manafort is strongly
denying all of that firing back in a
powerful statement it reads quote this
story is totally false deliberately
libelous I have never met Julian Assange
or anyone connected to him I've never
been contacted by anyone connected to
WikiLeaks either directly or indirectly
I have never reached out to Assange or
WikiLeaks on any matter now Manta Ford
is also vowing to pursue all legal
options against that paper and WikiLeaks
by the way they are even going further
tonight they tweeted quote willing to
bet the Guardian a million dollars and
its editors head that mana fort never
met Assange Assange too rightly so
moving ahead on possible legal action in
addition to being absolutely rebuffed by
both parties involved what's fascinating
is the Guardian story filled with
serious flaws and by the way no evidence
of any meetings vaguely described
sources and none on the record
remember the Ecuadorian Embassy in
London it is one of the most surveilled
and secured buildings in the world I
know I went there I interviewed Julian
Assange in January of 2017 visitors have
monitored they are photographed
videotaped by multiple governments and
now the Guardian is even being accused
of quietly stealth editing the story now
the paper actually altered their own
headline adding words sources say they
didn't have that in the beginning and
then they soften key elements in the
language just hours after receiving all
the backlash and while the fake news
media jumps on anything
everything Russia except Hillary's phony
dossier regardless of any actual
evidence president Trump's not backing
down and today he had sharp words for
Robert Muller he tweeted quote the phony
witch hunt continues
Muller and his gang of angry Democrats
are only looking at one side not the
other wait until it comes out how
horribly and viciously they are treating
people ruining lies for them refusing to
lie Muller is a conflicted prosecutor
gone rogue and then Trump continued
quote and the fake news media builds Bob
Muller up as a saint when in actuality
he is the exact opposite he's doing
tremendous damage to our criminal
justice system where he is only looking
at one side not the other heroes will
come of this and it won't be Muller and
a terrible gang of angry Democrats look
at their past look where they come from
and look at this 30 million dollars -
witch hunt continues they've got nothing
but ruin lives where is the server
meaning Hillary's server let these
terrible people go back to the Clinton
Foundation and the Justice Department
still president Trump is letting the
process play out he told The Washington
Post tonight he has no intention of
stopping the investigation but the
president's concerns are being echoed by
legal scholars like Alan Dershowitz who
warned today that Muller's about what
Muller's true motives really are let's
take a look Muller is not going to
produce a neutral report he's not going
to be fair he's going to produce what he
believes is going to be a devastating
attack he's gonna put together
everything he's gonna use information
from manna for and others without
necessarily disclosing that there will
hires and so the president seemed has to
be ready this is exactly what I have
been saying on this program from the
get-go our own gregg jarrett is explain
what we're witnessing now is the classic
Muller Andrew Weissman pit bull tactics
using threats coercion to get people to
what we call test the lie in other words
tell us what we want to hear and guess
what we're gonna go easy on you and by
the way if you don't tell us what we
want to hear well you might spend the
rest of your life in jail but look
what's happening this is fascinating
Paul Manafort and jerome corsi they're
now taking a stand they're refusing to
cooperate and go along with the test the
lies scheme they're not willing to
tell a story that they want told even
both of them elderly men risking life in
prison they could say exactly what these
rogue prosecutors want to save
themselves but clearly their conscience
refuses to allow them to lie CNN
reporting that Robert Muller has his
hands on 2016 email communications
between Corsi and Roger stone supposedly
showing some attempt from stone to seek
information from WikiLeaks we'll see how
this plays out as Muller continues to
turn the screws on both cores Ian stone
one thing is I have read it it doesn't
show that they knew anything was stolen
in any way by anybody anyone ever hear
the Pentagon Papers just a thought
remembered is now Dave 559 of Muller's
destroyed Trump which on zero evidence
zero of Trump Russia collusion we've got
all lying to the FBI lying to
prosecutors lying on loan applications
didn't pay your taxes where's the
collusion why not go after Hillary what
we're seeing here is a two-tiered
justice system Hillary Clinton paid for
phony Russian lies that were fed to you
the American people to influence the
2016 election and no legal consequences
the president Trump everyone associated
with him they turn the screws ever so
tight Muller and his merry band of
partisan investigators with a horrific
track record it's a travesty of justice
it is the biggest abuse of power
corruption scandal we've had never mind
Hillary Clinton from the get-go got
exonerated no real investigation they
were writing our exoneration in May they
didn't interview her and 17 other people
till July she committed obvious and
clear felonies including obstruction
when she deleted and she acid-washed and
then busted up devices but America's
left and their friends in the mainstream
media they can't get enough but they
never talk about the dual justice system
the Hillary system and then the system
for the rest of us completely obsessed
with a phony Trump Russia collusion
conspiracy theory and meanwhile the
destroy Trump press
is all but ignoring the major scandal
surrounding what might be the world's
sketchiest so-called charity the Clinton
Foundation back in the news
federal investigation is now currently
underway into Bill and Hillary's prize
so-called nonprofit organization FBI
agents are seeking to determine whether
or not the Clintons employed an illicit
pay to play scheme for years remember
during Hillary's 10 years then-senator
then Secretary of State and during her
two runs for the presidency that
Foundation raked in tens and tens of
millions of dollars many of the largest
donations coming from foreign
governments we're talking about millions
of dollars from Australia Norway the
Netherlands Ireland and remember Hillary
Clinton's you know claim to be the
champion of women during the 2016
campaign her foundation took in tens and
tens of millions of dollars from
countries with the most despicable
disgusting horrific human rights track
records Middle Eastern countries
practicing Sharia treating women like
second third class citizens and worse
and the Clinton Foundation taking
between ten and twenty five million
dollars from Saudi Arabia forbids women
from traveling without a male Guardians
permission persecutes Christians and
Jews and literally gives the death
penalty to gays and lesbians what did
they do they took millions from these
countries and they bought the Clintons
silence and they took more from Kuwait
and Qatar Brunei and Oman and UAE
Algeria they bought her silence
she never criticized those atrocious
human rights record like we have
regularly on this show and at 2016 alone
the foundation took in a whopping get
this the year she's running sixty two
million dollars in 2017 after Clinton's
devastating loss to Donald Trump her
foundation only received twenty six
million in donations well that's a huge
massive drop and that's because after it
became clear that Hillary Clinton would
never be President so what were all
those big donors hoping to gain from
their enormous deposits into the Clinton
Foundation looks to me like that's
called access pay-to-play paid access at
the highest
levels of our federal government imagine
for a second Donald Trump ever did this
you know you're buying access that no
other law-abiding citizen would ever
dream of do you think they get
invitations to the White House you think
they get access to the president if she
had one access to the the Senate seat
when she had that the State Department
when she was Secretary of State and if
everything went according to plan
access to the Oval Office of course
everything didn't go according to plan
and Hillary Clinton lost because you we
the people well Donald Trump became
president in spite of all of the deep
state's efforts to prevent that from
happening
now they delegitimizing and frankly we
will see in the next two years nothing
but an all-out effort assault to destroy
the presidency of Donald Trump and now
we have the opportunity to uncover what
looks like a completely corrupt pay to
play scheme that should have no place in
this constitutional republic of ours and
the mainstream media they choose to
ignore this developing scandal of course
there are all things Democrat they're an
extension of the Democratic Party
they're too busy covering stormy stormy
and whole whole etc they don't want to
cover the crisis at the southern border
at least not in a fair way an honest way
now that thousands of migrants have
arrived south of San Diego the biased
press can no longer ignore the serious
situation or pretend that it's some
grand conspiracy theory cooked up by the
GOP to get votes in the midterms instead
the media's echo chamber is now spinning
out of control over the use of
non-lethal tear gas why to disperse a
massive group of migrants that attempted
to break all of our laws rush the border
and many assaulting our own Border
Patrol with rocks and bottles and other
projectiles and we have it on tape take
a look bad things breaking out at the
San Ysidro Port of Entry near Tawana the
president falsely described the caravan
as an invasion now he seems intent on
trying to make it as ugly as he imagined
it is there any defense for using tear
gas on children well I think what
Americans really should be
especially Trump supporters people who
you know don't quite see the inhumanity
that's going on here who maybe think
that three-year-olds need tear gas there
has got to be a pragmatic and
compassionate answer here that does not
involve tear gassing children here we
look at children yet being subjected to
tear gas that's the United States
causing that that's outrageous he wants
that chaos on the border as he continues
to treat these people who so many of
whom are leaving violent lives in
Central America like terrorists there's
some bad people yeah yeah like bad 4
year old they got tear gas the other day
and as you can see your mainstream media
doing anything everything to vilify
President Trump and his administration
over the crisis at our southern border
however as per usual they have
completely failed to tell the whole
truth look at this study tonight from
News Buster's last night networks
totally ignored the use of tear gas
during the Obama administration
do you remember this kind of hysteria
report from the Washington Times shows
that Oh tear gas was used about once a
month during Barack Obama's time and
office in order to repel migrants at the
border once a month think about that now
isn't that all you need to really know
about the bias of the media in this
country there was no monthly outrage
over the actions of the Obama
administration no grandstanding no
dramatic pleas for civility no talk
about women and children this shows
without any shadow of a doubt to destroy
Trump press and that's who they are or
willing to do and say anything
everything to damage the administration
this has been two years and ongoing many
on the Left try to paint the Trump
administration as monsters the
statistics the truth history tells a
much different story in fact a hundred
thousand asylum claims were processed
last year under the Trump administration
by the way that happens to be a
record-setting amount that's up 6,000
from Obama's final year in office and
under the Trump immigration applications
into the United States they have surged
probably because of the better economy
unfortunately this causes serious
backlogs
we now are currently at 786,000 pending
immigration cases now keep in mind the
US has received 160,000 asylum cases
this year compared to just 42,000 in
2008 good economy again as of September
there were 42,000 likely illegal
immigrants held in ice detention
facilities despite only enough funding
and capacity for 40,000 people now the
president has requested more funding for
ice but as we know and as we can see
America's immigration resources are
stretched as extremely thin they are
operating at maximum capacity and this
makes the situation at our southern
border even more serious and more
dangerous for those people that put
their lives on the line to protect our
country our sovereignty our borders our
rule of law none of this seems to matter
to the left president's working hard to
improve the lives of the American people
and our immigration system strengthen
our waters ask people to respect our
laws and the left is working overtime to
destroy the reputation of the Trump
administration no conspiracy theory is
too absurd for them no lie too egregious
no rhetoric too disgusting and when
Democrats take control of the house in a
few short weeks I digress here a second
when they do oh we have great things
planned it's only going to get worse
mark my words two years never ending
non-stop attacks non-stop investigation
what are they going to do for you we the
people to improve the economy to improve
our security to bring us the energy
independence probably nothing